que sea un leve llamado a una tregua
Nacional del gobierno peruano El sexto
día de protestas en Lima culminó con una
nueva y violenta represión de las
fuerzas de seguridad casi siete mil
uniformados desplegados en la capital
que lanzaron gases lacrimógenos e
incluso perdigones para disuadir a la
multitudinaria manifestación dejando
decenas de heridos varios menores y
miembros de la prensa
tregua no hay con una asesina No puede
haber tregua con un congreso dictador la
señora de una vez tiene que entender
debe renunciar si quiere tregua El Perú
profundo de las comunidades campesinas
los pueblos originarios afectadas por la
minería transnacional Vamos a continuar
hasta las últimas consecuencias el
martes la presidenta Dina boluarte
reiteró su apoyo a las fuerzas del orden
y rechazó su dimisión principal reclamo
de los peruanos en las calles alegando
que las protestas zonas usadas por
grupos radicales este miércoles el
embajador peruano ante la ONU dijo que
investigara los abusos policiales en el
marco del estallido social somos
respetuosos de Legítimo derecho a la
protesta pacífica especialmente por
causas vinculadas a desigualdades
históricas y estructurales que debemos
superar lamentamos que las protestas
violentas
menos caben y distorsionen demandas
sociales importantes los bloqueos se
sucedieron también en el sur del país la
región de puno las autoridades
extendieron diez días más el toque de
queda y boluarte envió a más de 500
militares a la zona precisamente son
estas regiones campesinas e indígenas
las que han puesto la mayoría de los más
de 60 muertos desde que iniciaran las
protestas antigubernamentales